hello rejects reg here John here a lot
of people oh what a lot a lot of people
have said that I must watch the doctor
strange weird trailer by how though
Jonesy must now when I did that when I
checked out rogue one I did some facial
expressions
hopefully Aldo would use them in the
next one someone teased that it might be
there oh boy I hope it is if not Aldo I
will not be now so watch your videos you
think you know
there's the summation
and just protect the world from physical
dangers we said guarded against the
mystical threats
oh hey how's the hair
cool it's pretty weird trailer try to
find heroes weapons watching the video
carefully okay okay alright we're doing
it right now
hey that makes me have one fine
just remember to credit me uh yeah
although Jones gets the credit there's a
link to the video now you know we have
not made something this one this cool oh
man that was [ __ ] awesome alright
let's find these weapons I think I saw
the shield and a hammer somewhere
all right let's play this on silent so
we can use our eyes more Baby Bottle who
has a baby bottle in the Morpho
nobody uses Charlie Brown as a weapon
and that's a hot dog it's like when you
look when you play this with no audio
you see so many things Roger Rabbit
daddy knows that before in the book
there's something there it's a very
difficult game although yeah although
are you doing man ok so I'm at 40
seconds maybe they're really really
hidden in them maybe they're like really
tucked away places no man we're looking
at every shot how challenging are you
trying to make this
I didn't see any of them Wow we're very
bad at this game no we're going to find
it alright alright provides
go back to the key let's see what we're
looking for
let's make note of what we're looking
for oh the the actual three items yeah
this is a hammer the okay and a veteran
battering Captain America shield and a
hammer a threatened ear or whatever
that's cool
okay first shot we're City nothing do
you see anything here let's see shitty
[ __ ] here
battering Captain America shield a
Thor's hammer
battering those kids never shut the [ __ ]
up no okay
balloons battery you have an America
shield what oh that's the whole thing's
not even in here is it okay there maybe
it's in this crowd some where is Captain
America's what's that if it's that far
back this of it the trailers almost over
or is it how old oh he's lying maybe
he's doing it for this exact reason so
that will look dumb / - yeah
dude we looked at every frame there's
Batman within these paper ready number
seven for you just trying to give us an
excuse to actually like pay it's a close
attention to the trailer
Alto Jones okay alright let's let's go
to the comments and see if someone is
pointed it must be really hard like they
must be really tough Man Captain America
shield on the screen at nine seconds
we're damn you Charlie Brown you were
just a red herring okay we're starting
from 7 seconds going to eight
we're on nine
go back to 9 now we're on 10 11 12 ACTU
9 is going right back to 9 what okay we
needed confirmation from other comments
between the doctors tweeted doctors oh
so is it this thing between them
oh is it here that thing oh it is it
damn that's really what has been
mentally tucked in there I was just like
this is just another brain scanner yeah
okay Thor's hammer
what was that 31 seconds Thor's hammer
we get inside alright we go deep Thor's
hammer in the background that's big okay
we're a 30 seconds
31 it's the Waldos shot
yeah the background is very broad thing
tiny and that blurred out okay okay
let's start
make it like a formation like Thor's
hammer in the background there's a whole
shot one shot okay let's look at the
next oh it's right here oh oh it's in
the shop back Benedict Cumberbatch well
done you gotta be looking minutes there
there
Batarang 42 seconds is that it right
there that's it it's right there ah
thing is - I was looking in that scene
like it's gotta be near that wallpaper I
just didn't look at the other oh wow
okay that one's noticeable so I'm not
sure that was Thor's hammer
I think it was sores hammer that's yeah
okay tough aim now you gotta make all
your videos like with this yeah yeah
yeah
I love Batman's newspaper by the way
that's fun I just don't want Batman's
newspaper forever where's Alda good snow
Batman's newspaper t-shirts now alright
well guys
Aldo Jones asked me to check this out
Aldo appreciate you putting me in there
forty seconds it's an honor to be inside
of one of your weird trailers very cool
to see you freaking out behind tildes
ones I love these weird trailers so Aldo
Jones subscribe to his channel watch
more of his awesome videos and really
take your time too this is actually
really cool going like frame by frame
yeah like the attention to detail he has
and I love that he does like those
little hidden gems more than just like
the three items he Annis look for like
there were things that I noticed going
frame by frame that I didn't notice
before yeah yeah so like Batman's news
people like bad a didn't catch that the
first time you know I was thinking that
as we're going to frame by a friend like
why didn't he include that's the coolest
part all right well I'm Greg this is
John where the real rejects subscribe
yada yada yada yada